- All right everybody we're back with
(screams) Angela Bassett!
(audience cheering)
So, Angela stars in 9-1-1
which you can see Monday's
on Fox if you're smart.
(Angela laughs)
The show is all about getting the job done
before time runs out.
Get where we're going here?
So right now Angela and I
are going to see how we do
under that kind of pressure.
I feel strong about how I'm gonna do.
Do you feel,
do you feel confident?
- I've seen you Kelly.
- [Kelly] Okay.
But we're on the same team.
- I know how competitive you are.
We are?
- Yes, we're on the same team.
Okay so we're gonna play,
"What's Creepin' Up on Me?"
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
♪ What's creepin' up on me? ♪
- This how this game works y'all,
Angela will start with
her back to the screen,
I will give her clues about
what's creepin' up behind her,
without saying the name
of the actual thing.
Then we'll switch sides,
and Angela will give me clues,
and she's gonna kill it,
she's gonna be amazing.
We can pass if one is too hard,
if we can correctly guess 10
things total in two rounds,
the audience will win a cool prize.
If we can't, we fail everyone.
(audience cheers)
- Oh, that's so good.
- Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- Okay, okay.
- I hope I'm ready.
Oh, lord.
- [Kelly] I'm totally ready, okay.
Okay so lets start the clock.
Here we go.
- Let me just.
Okay, go.
Oh its what you get in
if there's an emergency,
and you have to be raced to the hospital.
- A gurney?
- No they come get you in this vehicle.
- Ambulance
- Yes!
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Oh this is like if you're on a mountain
and like, all of sudden
stuffs start coming down,
- An avalanche?
- Yes.
- Ooh!
(audience cheering)
- That was good.
Oh so this,
he looks, this animal is like
high on a tree all day long,
just eating eucalyptus.
- Koala bear.
- Yes, yes.
(bell dings)
(audience cheering)
- Oh, you played her!
She's amazing!
- Tina Turner?
- Yes!
- Aah!
(audience cheering)
- Okay so this, oh that's very specific.
So this is something you find
at a kid's birthday party,
and their noses honk.
- A red?
- Yeah, there noses honk.
- A clown.
- Okay, but the next part of it
is they're,
what do bank robbers do?
- Steal. Murder clowns.
- They steal? What do
they steal from the bank?
- Money. Money clowns.
(bell dings)
- Clear, stealing bank.
That was so specific.
(air horn)
Oh, that was so specific.
(audience cheering)
- I'm still confused.
Money clowns?
- I was, clown stealing money.
We got it.
- [From Behind Camera] Now you switch.
- [Both] Okay.
- Now we gonna switch.
- My turn.
- Okay, okay.
- Okay lets...
- [Kelly] Angela's giving the clues now.
- You gave great clues.
- So lets start
the clock and go.
- Oh, lets go to Paris and go the iconic
- Eiffel Tower
- Yeah.
(bell dings)
(audience cheering)
- Woo! I'm in a movie, a cat.
- You're a cat, Black Panther!
- Yes!
(bell dings)
(audience cheers)
- Honey, we were talking
about this earlier,
out in the sea, just let
them take me, eat me.
- Like a man?
(audience laughing)
- I'm not a man,
I'm an animal.
An animal! An Animal!
Sharp teeth.
- what are we talking about?
- Shark! Shark!
- Yes!
(bell dings)
- I was like what?
(laughing) I said man.
- All right.
I'm a Leo.
- You are a Leo, you're a lion?
- Yes
(bell dings)
(audience cheering)
- I was like what?
We're amazing!
- Athena and my mode of transportation.
- Oh, a cop vehicle,
(stutters) a police car.
- Yes!
(air horn)
(imitates air horn)
- We are amazing!
(Angela screams happily)
(screams) We are amazing!
- We rock you win!
(audience applauding)
- You're welcome!
- [Angela] You win!
What do you win? What do they win?
- Okay. And that means everyone wins.
so Clawee is a one-of-a-kind
real world arcade experience
in-mobile app that you can play live
from the comfort of your own home.
Players operate real claw
machines with their phones,
to grab prizes like
toys, plushies, jewelry
and home goods.
The best part is when you win a prize,
its sent directly to your front door.
Technology is cool y'all.
Everyone in the audience,
be sure to download Clawee,
because you're all getting
10,000 coins to start playing
and $300 Visa card.
(cheering)
Thank you so much Angela!
Everyone be sure to watch
9-1-1 Mondays on Fox,
where you can find just as
much urgency and excitement
as in that game. Almost, we we're amazing.